[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 15 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de ces de cette
édition tout le mois de novembre ces
mots bender événement dédié à la
sensibilisation au cancer masculin cette
semaine la clinique des franciscaines à
versailles consacrer une journée à la
prostate
l'organe concerne environ 26 % des
cancers chez les hommes
maurepas aura son multiplexe l'année
prochaine la première pierre du chantier
a été posée la semaine dernière
l'arrivée du cinéma qui se situe dans un
projet plus global celui de redynamiser
le village des loisirs dans la zone
paris ouest et grégory gary astier maire
de maurepas sera en plateau et en ce
moment à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
la huitième semaine des écrivains
persécutés emprisonnés empêché dans ce
cadre la batterie de guyancourt
accueille ce soir est des écrivains et
journalistes en exil invités de ce
journal telma chicoine a journalist
zimbabwéenne en exil et jacques fournier
directeur d itinéraire poétique
ils se sont rassemblés ce matin devant
la gare des chantiers à versailles les
cheminots accompagné d'associations
d'usagers des transports organisait une
journée de mobilisation motifs protester
contre un plan de suppression de 35
postes pour les lignes n et u il va
entraîner selon les syndicats la
réduction de l'amplitude horaire
d'ouverture des gares autre point de
mécontentement la fin de la vente des
billets grandes lignes aux guichets des
gares franciliennes dès janvier 2019
propos recueillis sur place par patrick
jacques de dixmude ces suppressions
d'emplois elles vont entraîner des
restrictions dans les horaires de
nombreuses gares qui seront fermés plus
tôt le soir qui ne seront pas ouvertes
le week end certaines gares ne sont
presque plus ouverte
donc c'est évidemment un problème pour
la qualité du service public ferroviaire
et bien sûr pour les usagers qui ont
besoin d'agents dans les gares de
l'ouverture à la fermeture du service
dans l'actualité du jour la pma
procréation médicalement assistée sera
bien étendu à toutes les femmes est
remboursé par la sécurité sociale le
gouvernement a confirmé aujourd'hui
cette disposition prévue par le projet
de loi bioéthique qui sera aidée examiné
au parlement
2019 dans les rues de versailles
aujourd'hui plusieurs opposants se sont
rassemblés à l'initiative d'alliance
vite à l association lance une campagne
nationale d' alerte sur l'impact de
l'extension de la pma aux femmes sans
partenaire masculin
interview de la déléguée départementale
collectées par manon varaldo compagnies
et des besoins essentiels des enfants
comme le besoin s'inscrire dans une leaf
dans une filiation biologique maternelle
dans une généalogie com le besoin de
connaître ses origines et comme le
besoin d'avoir à faire dans sa vie si
l'état s'apprête à organiser la halle à
la création et à organiser et à financer
d'ailleurs avec l'impôt la naissance
d'enfants sans père
et ça c'est un basculement majeur et
c'est une très grande injustice qui le
fait à ses enfants les femmes on toque
top rose les hommes mauvais beurre dans
un cas comme dans l'autre il s'agit de
sensibiliser aux maladies mardi
l'hôpital les franciscaines de
versailles délia une journée à la
prostate organes exclusivement masculin
à des conférences et une prostate géante
étaient notamment présents pour informer
patrick jacques de dixmude et mélanie
poké visé le col de la vessie et donc
c'est vraiment l'entrée dans la prostate
avec à partir de ce point là la prostate
la prostate
objet de toutes les attentions et
l'hôpital des franciscaines de
versailles avec cette reproduction
géante les spécialistes sensibilise la
prostate est un organe qui se situe en
aval de la vessie dans le périnée ou
disons dans le dans le petit bassin des
hommes exclusivement des hommes et qui a
pour rôle de servir à la fois à produire
une partie du liquide séminal est à la
fois de servir en quelque sorte
d'aiguillage entre la voie urinaire et
la voix séminal un organe qui évolue
avec l'âge les symptômes apparaissent à
partir de 50 aux deux maladies sont
fréquentes
la dénommée le cancer la prostate évolue
au cours de la vie d'un homme lorsqu'il
est plus jeune elle a tendance à être
plus petit et puis au fur et à mesure de
la vie elle va grossir progressivement
cette croissance s'accompagne de
l'apparition de symptômes plus ou moins
gênantes
un dépistage est recommandé à partir de
50 ans chaque année environ 100 mille
nouveaux patients présentent des
symptômes d'adénome près de 2 millions
d'hommes souffrent d'une maladie bénigne
ce samedi grande journée de mobilisation
citoyenne dit des gilet jaune des
rassemblements sont prévus partout en
france contre la hausse récente des prix
du carburant dans le sud des yvelines il
pourrait y avoir trois zones de blocage
sur les axes que vous voyez sur cette
carte sur l'autoroute a10 au niveau du
péage de saint-arnoult sur la nationale
10 à hauteur de rambouillet et sur la
nationale 12 non loin de méré
information à prendre avec la plus
grande précaution car elles peuvent à
tout moment évolué dans le reste du
département des opérations pourraient
également se dérouler sur l'autoroute
a13
premier invité de ce journal avec moi en
plateau gregory gary astier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le maire les
républicains de maurepas président et
précisons également que vous êtes
également vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de la
stratégie commerciale alors maurepas
aura bientôt son multiplexe un projet à
14 millions d'euros 8 salles de cinéma
et un bardage extérieur en bois qui
verront le jour en octobre 2019 dans la
zone paris ouest juste en face du
village des loisirs
on parlait de ce projet depuis dix ans
ils étaient attendus par la ville oui il
était très attendue parce que quand le
village des loisirs a été créé en 2009
le cinéma devait sortir de terre en même
temps pour servir de locomotive et pour
attirer évidemment des clients et le
consommateur dans cette nouvelle
extension commercial de paris ouest
cela ne s'est pas fait malheureusement à
l'époque il ya eu divers recours
et quand je suis arrivé aux
responsabilités j'ai repris le dossier
en main j'ai été défendre le dossier en
commission nationale d'aménagement à
signer cinématographique pardon qui
avait dans un premier temps on refusait
absolument la commission départementale
avait refusé ensuite la cena c'est ça a
été en conseil d'état
on a gagné en conseil d'état et ensuite
la cena c'est validé le projet qui
aujourd'hui sort de terre c'est à dire
que ces dernières années on peut les
comparer à un véritable combat pour voir
ce projet aboutir
oui c'était un véritable de combat qui a
été mené d'ailleurs par mon prédécesseur
avant moi que que j'ai repris ce que je
le jeu l'estiment bon pour la
collectivité bon pour la commune pour la
vitalité de la zone gérait aussi d'une
zone commerciale et industrielle qui
existe qui s'appelle paris ouest qui a
été créée en 1973 qu'il faut faire
rayonner qu'il faut dynamiser et à ce
titre le cinéma était très attendu
également des commerçants qui
travaillent dans la zone d'activité et
au village des loisirs et qui parfois
ont investi toute leur vie dans leur
fonds de commerce
qu'est-ce qui a fait pencher la balance
quels sont les arguments que vous avez
avancé pour que ce projet aboutisse au
final
à l'époque c'était justement ce que je
ne vous dire des éléments stratégiques
et de pour sauver le village des loisirs
parce que quelque part il manquait d'une
grande locomotive vous savez on est dans
un secteur quand même qui est hyper
concurrentiel et puis c'est une offre
culturelle aussi qui n'existait pas sur
le territoire de maurepas même s'il
existe d'autres cinémas aux alentours et
qui a été finalement retenue par la
commission nationale
c'est que du fait que le cinéma de
plaisir ne se faisait pas il a été
retenu celui de maurepas qui est en zone
secondaire je le rappelle la zone
d'activités paris ouest n'est pas
abordée par la nationale 10 et à ce
titre cette locomotive était la
bienvenue mais c'est vraiment la
locomotive qui manquait le village des
loisirs vous l'aï dit a été créée en
2009 et est ouvert depuis 2009 la pour
vraiment le redynamiser c'est la
locomotive qui lui manquait c'est
l'aboutissement le village des loisirs
du loisir et de la culture et le cinéma
a toute sa place
et puis j'allais dire maurepas est de
retour pendant très longtemps toutes les
autres villes se sont développées et moi
je refuse que maurepas devienne la
banlieue de saint quentin en yvelines
donc à ce titre là également
maurepas retrouve toute sa place dans le
développement économique et en tant que
mère je défends les intérêts de la
commune c'est une zone de loisirs qui
comprend notamment un une zone de
bowling du pardon des salles de sport un
laser quest c'était aussi dans le
contrat les les commerçants qui sont
installés dans cette zone de loisirs qui
est ce ce multiplex qui puisse attirer
du monde à ce village des loisirs
services l'alors a été vendu de cette
manière et donc et je disais ils ont
investi beaucoup d'argent dans leur
fonds de commerce
on a bientôt d'ailleurs une nouvelle
activité destinée à la réalité virtuelle
qui va arriver dans la zone d'activités
donc voilà on va impulser une nouvelle
dynamique et pour moi c'est le début
d'une nouvelle ère dans la zone
d'activité industrielle et commerciale
qui doit muter voulait on l'a dit tout à
l'heure vous occupe également la
stratégie commerciale à 50 en une c'est
donc un sujet que vous maîtrisez d'avoir
aussi sois là ce multiplex dans la zone
paris ouest
on peut dire ça va stimuler aussi le
commerce on va pouvoir faire du shopping
faire des loisirs avec ce village
également se faire une séance de cinéma
s'est dit on est d'accord on passera
mais voilà ces multiples et
complémentaires et après à chacun d'eux
dit trouver le plaisir là il veut il
veut y aller en fait alors vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure un projet de multiplexe à
plaisir alors il y en a un nouveau qui
est dans les cartons un futur un futur
multiplexe qui pourrait voir le jour
dans le centre commercial open sky alors
cinémovida qui est le gestionnaire du
futur multiplexe à maurepas a déposé un
recours au sénat c'est contre ce projet
vous serez à leurs côtés le 21 décembre
en tant que soutien lors de leur passage
devant la commission pourquoi ce j'y
serai en tant que mère évidemment pour
défendre les intérêts du cinéma de mort
pas ce qu'il ya de drôle dans cette
histoire c'est que quand le cinéma de
maurepas qui avait été proposé par
cinémovida en 2010 avait été refusé à
l'époque parce que celui de plaisir
devait se faire et avec le temps
la décision de faire cinéma de plaisir
est tombé puisqu'il ne s'est pas fait du
coup celui de mort pas été autorisé et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans le sens
inverse c'est à dire que celui de
maurepas sort à peine de terre qu'on
autorise quelques mots avant
notre cinéma sur le bassin de sur la
ville de plaisir
alors c'est ça paraît quand même
surprenant d'autant plus que la zone de
chalandise est pratiquement identique
notamment avec à l'épicentre
l'ugc de montigny a jugé aussi qui va
voir le jour au chesnay exactement dans
cet enclos l'isi également qui s'étend
et c'est un sujet c'est aussi qui est
proposée sur la ville de plaisir et
j'allais dire que pour le moment il faut
attendre plutôt que le cinéma ne mord
pas fasse ses preuves
sorte de terre fonctionne pendant
quelques temps avant d'en créer un
nouveau qui va de toute façon entrer en
concurrence puisque les deux tableaux
sans quatre cent mille visiteurs et ils
vont aller manger de toute façon aussi
sur le cinéma ugc de skywest je rappelle
que skywest s'y rencontrent des
difficultés
on y travaille pour essayer de
redynamiser évidemment le bâtiment donc
il faut faire aussi très attention on
est dans un secteur hyper concurrentiel
donc je pense que les deux projets qui
sortent en même temps c'est une erreur
il faut attendre que celui de maurepas
puisse bien fonctionné avant d'engager
celui de plaisir et je conclurai là
dessus sur le fait que l'open sky de
plaisir n'a pas besoin du cinéma pour
vivre alors que le village des loisirs a
besoin de sa locomotive pour exister et
ce passage devant la commission est
prévue le 21 décembre merci grégory gars
ici et d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes le maire les républicains
de maurepas merci aux actualités
économiques encore avec une journée de
recrutement ce jeudi à coignières la 16e
édition de ce rendez-vous se dérouler
toute la journée au salon antoine de
saint-exupéry 38 recruteurs sur place
pour rencontrer des personnes en
recherche d'emploi comme cette
entreprise de services à domicile
basée à trappes qui vient depuis une
dizaine d'années sur place écoutez
écoutez là c'est au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est un plus il ya bien sûr d'autres
moyens pour recruter mais le forain oui
c'est important ça permet voilà deux
d'avoir un contact physique avec avec
les personnes aussi bien recrutement que
même potentiellement des nouveaux
clients qu'on fait déjà une première
sélection ici parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de personnes qui défilent tout
au long de la journée
donc on récolte les cv
regard voilé disponibilité des personnes
leur lieu d'habitation qu'il faut qu'ils
habitent sur le secteur de 50 ans est
très important pour pouvoir y travailler
chez les clients et ensuite si voilà le
profil nous correspond on va donc fixé
un rendez-vous semaine suivante pour
recevoir ces personnes là qui était
potentiellement voilà intéressés par
notre entreprise coignières qui
connaîtra dans quelques semaines le nom
de son nouveau maire une élection
municipale partielle est programmé suite
à la démission de l'ex édile jean-pierre
sevestre premier tour le dimanche 25
novembre ce soir le 7-8 politique sera
d'ailleurs spécialement consacré à ce
scrutin où il friedrich y recevra les
trois têtes de listes candidates didier
fischer ali bousselham et david
pelletier le cetud politique c'est à
retrouver à partir de 20h sur tv 78 à
elancourt le gymnase lionel terray va
faire peau neuve un site sportif
utiliser tous les jours par le milieu
scolaire et associatif un projet de
reconstruction démolition nécessaire
avec la dégradation du bâtiment vieux de
plus de 40 ans les détails de nicolas
landry
les premiers coups de pelle ont commencé
en septembre 2018 la préparation des
fondations du nouveau gymnase lionel
terray coût global du projet 5 millions
d'euros avec des aides de la région du
département et de saint quentin en
yvelines
on est parti sur un gymnase plus modeste
en terme de taille puisque on sera sur
un seul niveau avec une grande salle
donc omnisports qui fera 1200 mètres
carrés un bâtiment au total qui aura une
capacité d'accueil de 1200 m² une salle
multisports et un espace pour les arts
martiaux le nouveau bâtiment sera
accessible au public à mobilité réduite
une reconstruction suivi d'une
démolition de la structure actuelle en
cause la vétusté du gymnase lionel
terray des interventions du service
technique chaque semaine après on voit
plusieurs fissures au niveau 2 du
bâtiment notamment les ferraillage qui
sont maintenant apparent la structure du
bâtiment et plus que vétuste et
aujourd'hui on en arrive jusqu'à
l'intérieur à avoir
vulgairement de l'humidité on est sur un
bâtiment qui est un des plus vieux de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines coût de 40 ans
mais qui devient vétuste donc avec de
gros problèmes structurels nous avions
aussi un bâtiment qui est très
énergivore
compte tenu de sa construction mais
aussi compte tenu qu'il est alimenté par
un chauffage est un chauffage commun à
la résidence des nouveaux horizons aux
alentours le collège et le lycée 17 mar
des utilisateurs de ce gymnase au
quotidien tout comme le milieu scolaire
et associatif
ce gymnase et le gymnase le plus utilisé
de la commune du fait de sa position
géographique
il est le plus central pour le coup nous
avons sept groupe scolaire élémentaire
et maternelle qui peuvent s'y rendre à
pied
la finalisation du nouveau gymnase est
prévue pour fin 2010 9 la démolition
pourra alors commencer à la place un
parc et des jardins devraient être créés
c'est un rendez vous habituel chaque
année à saint quentin en yvelines la
semaine des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêcher se tient en ce
moment dans l'agglomération huitième
édition de ce rendez vous ce jeudi à la
batterie de lui en cours à 20h30 cette
soirée ma poésie ne parle pas du songe
une soirée en présence d'écrivains et
journaliste en exil l'une d'entre eux
est avec nous en plateau
thelma chicoine à mon soir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes une journaliste
zimbabwéenne en exil en france alors
vous allez nous parler de votre histoire
d'ailleurs pour traduire vos propos jean
luc d'espagne c'est avec nous en plateau
merci de votre présence mais soir à vous
soit également pour soir à jacques
fournier bonsoir grégory vous êtes le
directeur d itinéraire poétique de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en préambule
déjà pour représenter cette semaine des
écrivains persécutés
il ya des rencontres organisées
notamment auprès des jeunes pour ifs
depuis lundi jusqu'au vendredi 12
rencontres dans dix établissements
scolaires des collégiens de 3e des
lycéens et lundi soir nous étions à
l'université pour rencontrer une
cinquantaine d'étudiants donc l'occasion
de rencontrer un ou deux de nos invités
de l'année donc tel massicois naquit la
nuit zimbabwe
ousmane dubaï a de guinée conakry et
monem rahama qui vient de du soudan
voilà trois écrivains qui peut être tu
es journaliste qui ont qui ont une
malheur de vouloir s'exprimer dans leur
pays et qui ont été tenus à subir les
foudres de leurs autorités d'états
taurian politiques religieuses ou
militaires c'est important de le redire
chaque année malgré les gros progrès en
termes de droits de l'homme de liberté
d'expression de liberté aussi de la
presse aujourd'hui endémicité en 2018
pardon il ya toujours des pays où on
peut on ne peut s'exprimer librement
abreu heureusement il y en a encore
c'est ce que je dis quand je rencontre
les jeunes je leur dis faites attention
vous vivez dans un pays certes
démocratique mais la démocratie est
fragile c'est le plus fragile des
gouvernements parce que c'est celui qui
est le plus attaqué un gouvernement
autoritaire il se défend une défense et
frontières il défend ces séances ont
bien une démocratie a toujours du mal à
se défendre parce qu'elle doit toujours
se justifier de son existence auprès de
tout le monde
autant de l'intérieur que de l'extérieur
et en france nous sommes dans une
démocratie donc nous sommes fragiles
donc cette fragilité elle elle peut être
défendu quand on sait ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur quand on sait comment on
peut être attaquée on peut être agressés
et donc montrer c'est ce ce combat d
écrivain poète romancier journaliste
blogueur dessinateur de presse nous
accueillons depuis huit ans parce que le
15 novembre est la journée de l'écrivain
en prison et ça on ne le sait pas assez
nous faisons en sorte que ces jeunes
puissent être armé à l'avenir et je leur
dis toujours s'il y en a quelques-uns
d'entre vous dans un an deux ans trois
ans qui se disent ouais je peux faire
quelque chose en rejoignant amnistie
internationale en rejoignant reporter
sans frontières ou d'autres d'autres
partenaires on arrivera à quelque chose
quand elle m'a parlons de votre histoire
vous êtes attirée les foudres des
autorités du zimbabwe pour notamment vos
articles critiques envers l'ancien
président robert mugabe vous avez subi
de nombreuses pressions
comment êtes vous arrivé à l'époque a
continué à écrire malgré tout sans subir
de pression à continuer dans cette ligne
de famille
et il fallait que quelqu'un fasse ce
travail que quelqu'un soit l'oeil soit
la parole soit les oreilles c'est elle
et la journaliste que j'étais j'étais
vraiment investi de cette mission
l'un de vos collègues à d'ailleurs
disparu vous n'aviez plus une nouvelle
ça ça vous a pas fait peur et peut-être
vous n'avez pas voulu arrêter à ce
moment là alors c'était un journaliste
connu qui a disparu mais il y en a des
moins connus aussi qui ont disparu
beaucoup mais de toute façon même si on
a peur le soir et la nuit
dès le matin on sait qu'on a une mission
de journaliste et qu'on doit aller
représenter le peuple
on l'a dit vos prises de position à
terre ont attiré la colère des autorités
alors rappelant cet épisode au moment
d'un départ pour la suite vous êtes
arrêté on vous confisque alors votre
matériel
et depuis la suède là où vous rendiez
vous apprenez que votre famille est
menacée
vous prenez à ce moment là décision de
plus retourner au zimbabwe ce que
c'était la décision la plus difficile de
votre vie
au québec sur not been able to go back
et des familles et oui ça a été la
décision la plus difficile de ma vie
parce que pour ma famille avait
l'habitude que lorsque je partais bien
je revenais et là je ne pourrais pas
revenir et en plus de mon activité de
journaliste j'avais également des
activités dans une organisation pour
défendre les droits civiques et donc je
savais aussi qu'en partant ça aurait des
conséquences terribles de ce point de
vue et vous êtes en france depuis 2010
est au sein de la maison des
journalistes
vous suivez bien sûr encore l'actualité
de votre pays ce important pour vous de
témoigner comme sa déculottée au cours
de cette soirée à guyancourt f notre il
détenait three different from what
j'analyse is like boys comme from every
night day my story is not only to invoke
riehling baril au batteur famille
politique et qui peut laisser continuer
my work
c'est très important parce que en fait
le journalisme qu'on pratique à
l'intérieur du pays
c'est peut-être aussi celui qu'on
pratique à l'extérieur avec plusieurs
activités s'est pas seulement informer
c'est aussi éduquer c'est peut-être
aussi divertir et elle a l'impression
que elle arrive à mener cette triple
mission ici en témoignant de tout ce
qu'elle a vécu
jacques fournier pour me pour terminer
nous restions en seconde je me retourne
vers vous là pour le programme de cette
soirée ça va être divisé dehors une
rencontre avec nos trois invités animée
par catherine points 1-1 bert et ensuite
une performance confié au collectif le
tympan marteau qui s'est emparée des
textes que je leur ai confié de
l'exposition que l'on montre depuis des
années dans les collèges et les lycées
qui s'appelle quelques nouvelles de
derrière les barreaux de d'écrivains de
poètes depuis depuis que federico garcia
lorca jusqu'à aujourd'hui on leur a
confié des textes et ils vont donner
écho de cela avec aussi la une
performance d'une peintre on dirait qu
une peintre iranienne je voulais
rapidement site et nos partenaires
investis international la maison des
journalistes
cette année nous avons travaillé avec
l'atelier des artistes en exil qui est
un endroit incroyable qu'ils disent à
paris depuis un an qui était mis en
place par la metteuse en scène judith
des pôles
nous travaillons aussi avec grâce à la
batterie à la ferme de bel ébat nous
sommes à la batterie et nous avons aussi
comme partenaire l'union des poètes et
compagnie merci et jacques fournier
d'avoir été avec nous thank you tell maé
et merci également à jean luc d'espagne
pour pour ca traduction et la soirée est
à suivre à partir de 20h30 à la patrie
de guyancourt et c'est gratuit
on a débuté ce journal à versailles on
va y retourner pour terminer la ville
vient de lancer un plan de rénovation de
1096 logements sociaux dans le quartier
bernard de jussieu est les travaux
concerneront les façades et l'isolation
thermique en parallèle 9 fresques
géantes seront dessinés sur les murs des
bâtiments reportage de michael et demi
d'euros un lifting d'envergure pour les
logements du quartier bernard de jussieu
à versailles les contours du futur
projet ont été dévoilés ce mercredi 14
novembre
l'isolation et les façades vont être
totalement refaite les artistes
internationaux vont également dessiné 9
fresque géante sur les pignons les
fresques elle même ne sont pas connus on
ne connaît que les artistes un buisson
qui ont été choisis
qui ont été choisis pour avoir des
fresques quand même assez élégante
quelque chose d'assez apaisants dans son
décor et donc les artistes maintenant
mon choix a travaillé sur le choix des
fresques avec le thème de la nature qui
leur a été imposée on veut quelque chose
d'apaisant des fresques élégante et
apaisante avec ses fresques la ville
espère pouvoir attirer dans le quartier
les habitants du centre ville mais
également des touristes français ou
étrangers sur le modèle de lyon
précurseur en la matière le quartier
bernard dufieux est accolée à la forêt
est donc un peu en cul-de-sac
au jour d'aujourd'hui ne vienne à
bernard de jussieu que des gens qui y
habitent ou viennent voir quelqu'un qui
connaisse à bernard de jussieu donc
l'intérêt des fraises qui est de faire
venir de l'extérieur dans ce quartier
donc de donner une fierté aux habitants
parce que ce leur quartier sera reconnu
par des gens de l'extérieur
une nouvelle accueillie avec
enthousiasme par les 6000 habitants du
secteur
au départ ils ont été un peu surpris
mais ils se rendent compte
que très vite et très vite en discutant
avec les artistes que ça va apporter un
plus la livraison définitive du projet
est programmée pour le premier trimestre
2001 21 coût total de l'opération plus
de 26 millions d'euros
et puis l'art urbain qui a décidément
investi aversa et vous avez peut-être vu
ses potelets customiser aux alentours de
la célèbre salle du jeu de paume dans le
quartier saint louis 25 ont été peints
par l'artiste le cyclope en personnages
qui ont marqué l'histoire de france
un roi comme louis saez ou encore
robespierre la rue coste quartier
porchefontaine accueillera également
prochainement des oeuvres d'art urbaine
sur le thème de la ville nature c'est la
fin du set 8 journal belle soirée avec
télé 78
[Musique]